Mesdames et Messieurs chers amis merci
chers François de m'avoir
invité à Guidel et merci de m'avoir
proposé de prendre la parole je suis
sensible je voudrais
je voudrais
c'est un remerciement sincère je
voudrais je voudrais saluer avant de
commencer à vous parler madame Monsieur
je voudrais saluer
Marc et Geneviève que je suis heureux de
retrouver ici après avoir
souffert parfois avec mais aussi
beaucoup riz avec eux dans d'autres
moments
et en tout cas après avoir pu pendant
trois ans compter sur leur loyauté sur
leur amitié je crois et sur leur
efficacité donc vraiment je les salue
avec beaucoup d'amitié
je suis je suis très heureux aussi de
retrouver Jean-Yves
et heureux et impatient j'arrive
car tu as tu as laissé entrevoir
discrètement c'est vrai mais néanmoins
explicitement que tu avais des talents
au platine
et je crois comprendre que
l'organisation d'événement laisse une
place importante à la dimension festive
ce soir
il faudra donc que tu nous montres que
les Bretons savent tenir leurs promesses
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais rassurer Jean-Paul Mattei
qui m'a vu saisir mon iPad la semaine
dernière il m'a vu à Fontainebleau et
quand j'ai saisi mon iPad j'ai ensuite
parlé pendant une heure et demie donc il
se dit merde serait trop pardon il se
dit zut je vais y avoir droit encore
pendant une heure et demie t'inquiète
pas ça va être plus court et enfin je
voudrais essayer de le dernier que je
voudrais remercier très très sincèrement
dans votre assemblée saloué saluer
Jean-Louis bourlange car grâce à lui
nous savons désormais nous avons
participé à une réunion politique
ensemble dans laquelle il a été dit que
Jean-Pierre Chevènement et l'OTAN
c'était pareil
je crois mesdames et messieurs
que personne ici
[Applaudissements]
que personne au sein de l'OTAN
et que certainement pas Jean-Pierre
Chevènement aurait pu imaginer une
pareille correspondante
je suis aussi de retrouver Stéphane je
le salue avec amitié et je vais
d'ailleurs revenir sur un certain nombre
de choses qui a dit parce que je les
partage tout à fait complètement en tout
cas je suis heureux d'être à Guidel vous
vous avez l'habitude de guider à elle ça
fait 10 ans je crois que que vous venez
à Guidel moi c'est la deuxième fois
alors la première fois c'était un
précédent la deuxième fois c'est le
début d'un usage
et je me réjouis et je me réjouis donc
vivement la vivement la prochaine je
rappelle à ceux qui l'ignoreraient
encore ce que j'ai appris c'est pour ça
que je le dis avec beaucoup de
certitudes il y a quelques heures que la
devise de Guidel c'était
loyal et fidèle toujours
c'est fait exprès
bien sûr loyal et fidèle toujours donc
très bien soyons loyaux et fidèle
toujours en général et à Guidel en
particulier je suis venu au fond pour
vous dire deux choses je voudrais dire
très simplement sans très simplement
la première et ça rejoint assez
largement ce qu'a dit Stéphane ça
rejoint aussi assez largement ce qu'a
dit François ce qui veut dire que comme
nous nous sommes pas concertés
ça veut dire que nous avons besoin de le
dire et que nous le croyons tous les
trois très sincèrement
l'esprit qui a présidé à la construction
de la majorité présidentielle doit
prévaloir quand je dis de l'esprit qui a
contribué à la
présidé à la construction de la majorité
présidentielle si cette idée cette idée
qui
est apparu progressivement comme toutes
les grandes idées elles se sont parfois
heurtés à la réalité mais l'idée que
nous allions construire une majorité
présidentielle sur le fondement de trois
blocs des blocs d'importance différentes
des blocs dont l'histoire était
différente dont le corpus idéologique
était différent dont l'âge de la
formation politique était différent
trois blocs
différents donc qui avait vocation
à s'entendre à se comprendre à se faire
confiance
ça n'est pas rien parce que dans la vie
politique française et dans l'histoire
de la constitution des majorités
on n'a rien inventé des coalitions des
regroupements il en a existé dans le
passé et probablement en existera-t-il à
l'avenir mais l'idée
de ne pas se cantonner à un bloc et bien
de reconnaître dans une majorité qui
était marquée par l'idée du dépassement
par l'idée que il ne fallait pas rester
assigner à son identité politique
d'origine même si on pouvait la
respecter l'idée de constituer un bloc
au pardon un ensemble c'est le cas de le
dire en trois blocs
et l'idée ça a été je pense qu'on peut
aller encore un peu plus loin dans cette
idée ça a été de constituer un système
dans lequel chaque bloc
est libre
libre et autonome
mais chaque bloc est relié par un lien
qui n'est pas simplement un engagement
verbal passablement une déclaration
politique mais des liens structurels qui
ne sont pas négligeables nous avons au
moment des élections législatives et ça
n'est pas rien présenter des candidats
sous une candidature commune
sous une candidature commune et l'effet
de cette candidature c'était que
lorsqu'il se déclarait en préfecture
comme ici il y a des gens qui savent à
peu près ce que c'est qu'une élection je
peux développer ce point là lorsqu'il se
déclarait en préfecture il se déclarait
sous le nom ensemble
ça veut dire que tout à fait conscient
de leur appartenance à une formation
politique
il ils affirmaient devant les Français
en toute transparence que leur formation
politique avait vocation appartenir à un
ensemble qui s'assumait comme tel pour
la répartition des financements pour les
déclarations en préfecture pour la
répartition des investitures c'est un
travail d'une grande intensité
et à mon avis tu as un très grand
intérêt qui a été réalisé par les trois
composantes de ce mouvement ensemble et
je voudrais puisque nous sommes en
Bretagne et puisque nous sommes à Guidel
dire que ce moment de travail très
intense avec François avec Richard
Ferrand
autre breton
je dis autre breton pas parce que je
suis breton personnellement je suis
normand c'est assez différent je dis
autre breton en regardant Jean-Yves
autre breton que je salue avec beaucoup
d'amitié avec la participation amicale
mais ferme de Marc feno
un travail à la fois passionnant
et sur lequel je crois nous pouvons
construire beaucoup
ça c'est ce que je voulais dire
et pour que cet ensemble
cette structuration de trois blocs je me
méfie parce que François sont en train
de prendre des notes
pour que ça marche
pour que ça marche il faut il faut
évidemment que nous tenions les
engagements que nous avons pris très
bien il faut que nous tenions les
engagements que nous avons pris il faut
que nous respections nos partenaires qui
sur l'essentiel je rejoins assez
naturellement François et Stéphane sont
d'accord mais qui ont parfois des
différences de vue soit en interne soit
globalement avec leur partenaire il faut
qu'il y ait une relation qui soit une
relation de respect et de confiance
et c'est facile de s'engager
et c'est difficile d'avoir la discipline
collective
de tenir cet engagement et donc je veux
dire deux choses sur ce point d'abord
que je ferai tout ce qui est en mon
possible exactement comme Stéphane la
déclaré exactement comme François le
fait pour tenir cette discipline cet
engagement que nous avons pris et je
voudrais saluer les efforts et la
qualité du travail effectué par la
première ministre
Elisabeth borne qui est extrêmement
attentive à cette discussion extrêmement
attentive à la qualité de nos échanges
et comme je sais que c'est pas facile
ben je la remercie encore plus
je vous assure
l'objectif l'objectif c'est évidemment
pas simplement de se faire plaisir en
constituant un ensemble à trois
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir permettre la
mise en place de quelque chose
ensemble qui de notre point de vue avait
vocation à la fois élargir le bloc
central et la majorité présidentielle et
d'une façon alors assiner et donc ce qui
est à l'oeuvre dans cet ensemble ça
n'est pas simplement une tactique
électorale de 2022 à mon sens ça n'est
pas non plus une forme de stabilisation
d'une majorité qui est apparue et devenu
une majorité relative c'est
véritablement je crois le support
durable du rassemblement futur de tous
les éléments du bloc central qui est
indispensable si nous voulons à la fois
conserver la la maîtrise des affaires
publiques et si nous voulons continuer à
faire avancer notre pays et donc je me
félicite et je voudrais le dire du
travail avec avec François intéressantes
a-t-il dit pour qualifier nos relations
et ça c'est juste ça c'est juste
le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que
ça n'était pas forcément à qui
faut reconnaître ça n'était pas
forcément acquis l'idée que ça puisse se
passer bien nous nous sommes assez
différents avec François de nous avons
au moment des élections législatives
fait deux concerts une campagne
électorale dans la belle ville petite et
belle ville de tonnerre dans l'Yonne
Bourgogne
et l'ordre de ce de cette de ce meeting
qui était un assez beau meeting
personnalité dans une très belle enfin
bon bref
lors de ce lors de ce meeting je me
souviens avoir dit et je pourrais le
dire dans les mêmes termes aujourd'hui
que il y avait quand même beaucoup de
différences entre nous
françois est un littéraire je suis un
juriste et il est il est ne l'ignore
Béarnais je suis moi-même normand
et ce sont deux caractères différents
il est il est montagnard je suis plutôt
porté vers la mer
il est et il a raison de l'être fier
d'être au fond le dépositaire et
l'incarnation la plus éminente de la
famille centriste qui puisse ses racines
dans l'histoire politique de la France
et je suis pour ma part plus sensible
sans être complètement insensible à la
famille centriste car je suis dormant
erwanais je suis d'abord à vrai ça c'est
compliqué
mais moi-même plutôt sensible à la
droite
du libéralisme à la française et à la
mystique gaulliste parce que on se
refait pas et donc évidemment toutes ces
petites différences qui sont jamais
rédhibitoires heureusement mais elle
compte à ça vous ajoutez quelque chose
stratégique différent dans la vie
politique dans les 20 dernières années
et bien vous avez tout ce qu'il faut
pour que ce soit plus compliqué
mais
et au fond c'est presque plus important
vous avez aussi
un certain sens de la litote
nous avons découvert avec François que
lui qui parle couramment le Béarnais moi
qui parle couramment le Normand les deux
langues avaient de fortes
correspondances lorsqu'il s'agit de la
litote
et puis encore plus sérieux parce que je
m'en voudrais de rester que sur un
registre léger je crois que nous
partageons sur beaucoup de points sur de
très nombreux points des convergences
d'analyses et une volonté de ne rien
lâcher pour que on essaie de s'en sortir
qu'on essaie d'avancer et qu'on essaie
d'être à la hauteur des enjeux et ça ça
compte ça compte même beaucoup et ça
compte même de plus en plus et donc en
dépit de tout ça ou grâce à tout ça je
crois pouvoir dire avec François je
crois aussi pouvoir le dire avec
Stéphane je crois surtout pouvoir le
dire avec l'ensemble des parlementaires
qui composent l'ensemble des trois
groupes nous avons le substrat commun
qui nous permet d'avancer à la condition
je le redis que
nous fassions prévaloir toujours
l'esprit qui a présidé à la construction
de la majorité présidentielle c'est la
première chose que je veux dire la
deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que
c'est très très bien de conserver cet
esprit c'est d'autant plus nécessaire
que nous allons quand même être
confronté à des trucs assez bizarre et
quand je dis bizarre je veux dire rude
je veux dire difficile c'est très facile
en ce moment d'avoir un discours
pessimiste parce que toute la raison
nous y conduit pour avoir un discours
optimiste il faut presque faire appel à
des catégories intellectuelles qui sont
moins la raison que la foi
ça compte je veux pas dire le contraire
ici en Bretagne mais c'est presque de
cette nature là nous allons faire face à
des choses qui sont difficiles François
l'a dit avec beaucoup de clarté il y a
quelques semaines dans un dans un long
article dans une longue interview qui a
qui s'est vu et qui a fait à juste titre
parler et réagir j'avais moi-même il y a
quelques mois ou quelques années parler
de tempête que je voyais venir Jean-Yves
a dit tout à l'heure avec beaucoup de
clarté tous les bouleversements et les
désordres du monde qu'il lisaient dans
les évolutions actuelles de notre
société de notre planète
nous sommes en face d'un
d'une transformation liée à des facteurs
extrêmement divers au bouleversement
géopolitique alors il y a la foi la
surpuissance chinoise il y a à la fois
le désordre russe en Ukraine il y a
l'avènement de plus en plus net de plus
en plus puissant et de plus en plus
dangereux me semble-t-il d'idées selon
lesquelles les démocraties occidentales
notre régime démocratique celui auquel
nous sommes attachés et peut-être
d'ailleurs pas suffisamment parce que ça
fait tellement longtemps qu'il est là
qu'on a l'impression qu'il sera toujours
là que notre régime démocratique nos
régimes démocratiques ne sont plus les
mieux placés pour garantir à la fois la
prospérité du monde et la stabilité du
monde mais pendant très longtemps on a
pensé ça on a pensé que de toute
évidence les régimes qui garantissaient
cette stabilité et cette prospérité avec
en plus la liberté c'était des régimes
démocratiques et qu'est-ce qu'on
constate aujourd'hui à la fois en termes
de prospérité économique à la fois en
termes de puissance militaire et à la
fois même parfois en termes de capacité
à répondre aux enjeux de la planète
l'idée selon laquelle au fond nos
démocraties serait trop faible trop
inefficace pour apporter des réponses
crédibles au sujet que nous devons
régler il y a là un changement
intellectuel une menace intellect je le
partage pas du tout cet avis je voudrais
qu'on soit très clair entre nous
mais cette idée là ce poison là cette
remise en cause là
elles sont extrêmement dangereuses et
elles sont extrêmement puissantes
bouleversement géopolitique ensuite
d'abord
urgence climatique
urgence climatique d'ailleurs c'est je
constate qu'au fur et à mesure
quel apparaît nous parlons de moins en
moins de développement durable et de
plus en plus d'urgence climatiques je
pense que dans l'évolution de la
sémantique il n'y a pas qu'un hasard il
y a une signification profonde c'est de
moins en moins la question du
développement durable qui se pose ou qui
nous occupent et de plus en plus la
question de l'urgence climatique et de
notre capacité à y apporter une réponse
crédible pas simplement une réponse mais
une réponse crédible qui s'oppose vous
l'avez tous vu pendant les campagnes et
si vous ne le voyez pas pendant les
campagnes vous le voyez forcément soit
pendant les déjeuners ou les dîners de
famille soit à chaque fois que vous
allez dans une université ou dans une
école et que vous vous prêtez au jeu de
la discussion cette urgence climatique
elle est le sujet numéro un et c'est pas
une mode le sujet numéro un des
générations un peu plus jeunes que moi
donc que nous
et c'est un énorme sujet et c'est un
énorme sujet qui va parfois jusqu'à
remettre en cause
l'idée de croissance l'idée de progrès
l'idée de liberté politique
l'idée de liberté individuelle
la question de savoir
lorsque vous écoutez des des gens qui ne
sont pas forcément des extrémistes
politiques mais qui vous disent au fond
l'état de la planète aujourd'hui impose
que nous nous posions la question qui
est très politique de savoir ce qui est
nécessaire et ce qui est superflu pour
nous concentrer sur le nécessaire et
pour abandonner une superflu mais
mesdames et messieurs politiquesment
déterminé ce qui est superflu c'est
redoutablement complexe je ne suis même
pas sûr que ce soit une bonne idée vous
voyez bien les affres politiques dans
lesquels nous allons être plongés pour
faire face à cette urgence climatique
qui est indispensable
c'est assez facile une fois qu'on a
saisi l'ampleur du vertige d'être un peu
pessimiste et puis il y a des effets
puissants sur nos vies de phénomènes
dont on parle trop peu je voudrais citer
deux très rapides parce qu'ils doivent
nous faire réfléchir premier phénomène
dont nous parlons vraiment très peu au
fond mais que nous vivons tous les jours
l'impact des révolutions technologiques
et des évolutions technologiques sur nos
vies sur la notion de liberté sur la
façon dont nous nous projetons à
l'avenir ses propres mots vertigineux
toutes les semaines tous les mois on
fait des découvertes scientifiques
ou des applications nouvelles
technologiques qui nous font passer
insensiblement des frontières que nous
pensions relativement posées peut-être
pas totalement ferme parce que quand
même mais relativement posé en matière
de biotechnologie et le Parlement sans
fait les cours heureusement et légifère
et heureusement sur les questions de
bioéthique mais en général illégifère
avec un peu de retard et le rythme
auquel ces évolutions se propagent et se
développent et proprement vertigineux
qu'est-ce que c'est la liberté dans un
monde où l'hyper connectivité et l'hyper
traçabilité deviennent la norme et
accessible à tout le monde qu'est-ce que
c'est la démocratie dans un monde où au
fond les lieux communs de débat sont
totalement émiettés
et où les communautés n'ont pas par
l'effet d'un choix mais par l'effet d'un
algorithme finissent par se renforcer
entre elles-mêmes la démocratie par
nature impose que nous sortions de
nous-mêmes et que nous discutions et que
nous discute que nous discutions avec
des gens qui ne sont pas d'accord
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux il
faut bien les reconnaître nous sommes
dirigés vers des gens qui pensent comme
nous et le renforcement des gens qui
pensent comme nous nous donnent le
sentiment on n'est pas tout seul et donc
on a raison
et il y a une perversion terrible du
débat public terrible et elle n'est pas
la seule mais vous voyez bien que la
menace que cela fait peser sur le débat
public la menace que ça fait peser sur
nos démocraties est absolument
considérable j'en arrête avec les
révolutions technologiques j'en viens à
un deuxième phénomène le phénomène
démographique je passe sur l'explosion
démographique à l'échelle de la planète
je dis juste juste cette chose dans le
quinquennat qui vient c'est pas dans 20
ans dans les 5 ans qui viennent
le nombre d'écoliers
de collégiens et de lycéens mais en
vérité d'abord d'écoliers ça va pas
tellement se voir au niveau du lycée ça
va surtout au niveau des écoles va
baisser de 500 000
500000 bon il y a beaucoup d'écoliers en
France mais enfin 500 000 ça va se voir
500 000 ça n'est pas rien 500 000 c'est
une une
interrogation collective considérable
sur le monde de demain
personne n'en parle on a tous et ici
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs un
attachement à la politique familiale non
mais tu as vu je me suis rattrapé quand
même
ici plus qu'ailleurs un attachement à la
politique familiale mais la vérité vraie
c'est que dans le débat public la
question de savoir le monde que nous la
France que nous nous préparons à 20 ans
alors que nous sommes dans une
génération très creuse
que nous devrons payer les retraites
aussi dans 20 ans
le presque déconnecté de la réalité donc
quand on met tout à bout et encore j'ai
beaucoup de choses que j'ai pas évoqué
on a le droit d'être un peu inquiet
et on a d'autant plus le droit d'être
traqué qu'on affronte ces sujets dans
une situation de relatif fragilité
relative fragilité alors heureusement
elle n'est pas générale cette fragilité
d'abord parce que la France et la France
qu'elle a de la ressource quelle est la
depuis longtemps qu'elle a des talents
extraordinaires qu'elle a et d'une
certaine façon nous l'avons vu mais
enfin elle était là bien avant nous elle
sera bien après nous et elle a des
caractéristiques qui font que elle a de
la ressource la France et puis aussi
parce que Stéphane lui raison de le
souligner
on n'est pas resté les deux pieds dans
le même sabot dans les cinq dernières
années et un certain nombre d'actions
qui ont été mises en œuvre lors du
dernier quinquennat il y a d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d'actions qui ont été mis
en oeuvre avant le dernier quinquennat
qui était bien aussi il y en a d'autres
qui étaient moins bien enfin on n'est
pas dans une dans une dichotomie ou nous
très bien les autres très mal c'est pas
vrai c'est pas ça la démocratie
on a quand même réussi à renforcer un
certain nombre de domaines bon je dis
l'apprentissage parce que c'est
probablement ce qui me réjouit le plus
mais enfin il y en a beaucoup d'autres
que je pourrais citer mais enfin une
fois qu'on s'a dit ça pour se rassurer
on est quand même face à des grandes
fragilités la crise les crispations
sociales
nous abordons des crises redoutables
avec un niveau de crispation sociale qui
est quand même extrêmement élevé le
malaise démocratique qui réel dans la
qualité du débat public dans le lien que
nos concitoyens tissent avec leur
représentants dans l'espoir qu'ils ont
que leur représentants trouvent des
solutions et la capacité d'ailleurs à
les accepter bref à bien des égards le
malaise démocratique il est perceptible
et il est évidemment extrêmement
inquiétant
dans une certaine forme aussi de
défiance de ce que nous sommes
j'ai toujours pris avec beaucoup de
distance les gens qui vous expliquer que
la France ontologiquement c'était mieux
que tout le monde que d'ailleurs les
Français étaient ontologiquement plus
intelligents que tous les autres et que
circuler il y a rien à voir et qu'on
avait le meilleur modèle pour tout ça
n'est pas vrai
mais il y a en France très fortement et
vous le voyez très bien une forme de
défiance de ce que nous sommes les
d'absence de de reconnaissance d'absence
de confiance d'absence de de plaisir de
joie et de fierté d'être ce que nous
sommes et quand je dis ça j'appelle pas
tout le monde à être naïvement
extrêmement fier mais je constate le
pessimisme
récurrent
les Allemands ont un mot pour ça
l'espèce de honte de soi dans laquelle
parfois parfois nous nous complaisons
qui d'ailleurs la contrepartie d'une
fierté qui me semble souvent excessive
et donc il est il est absolument
indispensable d'avoir conscience que
notre tissu national notre nation bien
loin d'être soudée autour d'un projet
elle est inquiète de se caler de ce
qu'elle est devenue
le fondement je prends deux sujets très
vite des choses qui apparaissent comme
des fondements de ce que notre pays
l'école
la sécurité sociale
l'école depuis longtemps la sécurité
sociale depuis 45 enfin vous avez là
deux fondements l'idée de dire que nous
nous sommes organisés pour avoir une
puissance publique l'État pour l'État
euh non l'État pour l'école et
l'organisation sociale pour la sécurité
sociale qui sont capables de répondre à
des besoins essentiels la santé d'un
côté l'école de l'autre et ben c'est
deux ils sont tous les deux en crise
en crise profonde
les gens les regardent en se disant ils
ne fonctionnent plus comme ils devraient
je n'y trouve plus mon compte
l'éducation et tout ce qu'elle devrait
amener à mes enfants n'est plus garantie
dans des conditions qui me paraissent
raisonnables
et beaucoup de nos concitoyens pensa et
l'accès aux soins et la qualité du son à
la qualité du son n'est pas en cause
en général n'est pas du tout en cause
mais l'accès aux soins est
redoutablement complexe et dans le genre
petit élément venant dissoudre la
confiance et éroder la force du tissu
national il y a pas mieux
donc vous avez ces deux piliers en crise
et vous avez cette défiance qui se qui
se poursuit si vous ajoutez à ça une
addiction à la dépense publique qui nous
a conduit à avoir des dettes qui sont
importantes là aussi telles que François
connaît par cœur et qu'il développe
depuis longtemps que je partage avec lui
et bien nous attaquons une période
difficile avec des fragilités elle ne
condamnant rien notre pays elle ne nous
condamne rien mais ne pas les voir ce
serait dangereux ne pas les voir serait
même probablement irresponsable je
prends un petit mot mais je dirais très
vite sur les retraites pas du tout pour
dire ce qu'il faut faire le débat lieu
j'ai pas envie de rajouter une petite
phrase je vais simplement vous dire ça
ça fait la première fois que j'ai
entendu parler de la question des
retraites j'étais en seconde et c'était
il y a longtemps croyez-moi
malheureusement c'était en seconde et
c'était mon professeur d'économie qui
était au tableau
il peut vous dire qu'il y avait pas
d'informatique il était au tableau il
nous a fait des courbes et nous a dit
voyez système de retraite un jour il va
y avoir un problème parce que de plus en
plus c'est la démographie
donc il va régler le problème c'était
presque simple sur son tableau
nous sommes un pays où depuis autant que
je m'en souvienne 35 ans
37 même si je compte
où nous savons qu'il y a un problème
où nous essayons de le régler ou parfois
nous apportons des pierres dans
l'édifice et d'une certaine façon tant
mieux mais où ce problème est devenu
constitutif de la crise de nerfs
national de notre incapacité à appuyer
nos décisions sur des chiffres et avoir
un débat rationnel et je le dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité parce que j'ai
beaucoup cotisé sur le sujet
pas pour le système de retraite aussi
mais mais sur le sujet donc je dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité je dis pas du tout
que moi je sais ce qu'il faut faire et
que les autres ils savent pas c'est pas
du tout ça que je veux dire ce que je
veux dire c'est que collectivement notre
pays depuis 35 ans 35 ans est empêtré
dans un sujet dont je me permets
d'observer qu'il a toujours été réglé
dans tous les pays comparables de la
même façon ce qui devrait quand même
nous laisser penser que
vous voyez il doit y avoir des solutions
et ben non
on tergiverse on se perd on hésite on
critique et on a le droit on manifeste
on a le droit aussi et finalement on ne
règle pas un problème d'une certaine
façon il ne faut pas s'étonner
que les générations les plus jeunes nous
disent écoutez l'urgence climatique
c'est vraiment compliqué à résoudre et
vous y arrivez pas ça c'est plus simple
les gens ils ont déjà réglé et vous y
arrivez pas non plus donc l'urgence
climatique vous n'y arriverez pas donc
il y a un problème vraiment de capacité
à faire avancer les choses et les
retraites
s'inscrivent dans ce sujet François a
dit très clairement et c'est
parfaitement respectable et en plus
c'est fondé sur une analyse qui est
souvent juste sa position moi j'ai dit
avec le même souci que François
d'arriver à la réforme
et la même lecture des difficultés qu'il
a pointé que quoi qu'il arrive
nous soutiendrions
fermement le gouvernement
mais décidons vite ne laissons pas
dérivés ce sujet cette hésitation décide
et faisons en sorte que soit on bouge
rapidement soit on bouge un peu moins
rapidement mais disons comment nous
allons faire nous n'avons pas besoin de
rajouter des hésitations à un sujet qui
est déjà assez compliqué me semble-t-il
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire et
voilà les sujets que on pourrait
développer sur l'école sur la justice
sur la justice
sur la santé mais je serais trop long si
je continue alors je voudrais terminer
par ceci qui intéresse Stéphane car la
semaine dernière j'étais au Congrès qui
a qui a permis la naissance de
renaissance
on peut le dire comme ça et je voudrais
dire combien je trouve que c'est un nom
extraordinaire
Renaissance la Renaissance dans la dans
notre
imaginaire dans notre histoire dans
notre culture la Renaissance est très
fortement associée à l'humanisme
Stéphane a eu raison de le dire
et l'humanisme dans le monde dans lequel
nous vivons n'est pas moins important
que dans le monde dans lequel cette
valeur est née
il y a quelque chose qui est m'a
toujours paru
non je devrais pas dire ça parce que si
je le dis ça va être mal interprété
en fait que j'ai toujours été un peu
agacé qu'on pense que la Renaissance
n'était que l'humanisme a eu des trucs
terribles pendant la Renaissance mais
terrible et que le moyen-âge aurait été
par définition la période la plus sombre
de notre histoire alors qu'il y a des
trucs glorieux pendant bref une fois
qu'on a dit ça et j'enlève toutes les
analogies que vous pourriez entendre je
reviens à cette idée que la Renaissance
me paraît glorieuse pas simplement pour
l'humanisme mais parce que elle est un
moment et elle est un moment qui nous
dit beaucoup de choses sur notre
situation aujourd'hui ou au fond deux
idées vont s'imposer je crois
et
se parler l'idée de fondation
et l'idée de réconciliation comme je
savais que j'allais venir ici j'ai lu
récemment un bon livre que je vous
recommande qui est une biographie d'un
roi qui est très très lié à une ville du
Béarn
Henri IV le roi libre dit l'auteur qui
dédit le livre aux amoureux de la
réconciliation bon et ben si on regarde
les deux les deux grandes figures de la
Renaissance française
c'est François 1er Henri IV et au fond
qui ont chacun leur pardon
surtout François 1er d'ailleurs
non mais
[Applaudissements]
François 1er il a dit
et il a des moments glorieux il a fondé
le Havre donc on lui pardonne tout mais
mais non sont deux figures je vais très
vite pardon ce sont deux figures qui qui
existent par l'idée de fondation et par
l'idée de réconciliation
la fondation d'un état François 1er et
Henri IV sont pénétrés de l'idée qu'il
faut créer une forme d'État qui va
devenir l'État moderne
la fondation par la culture c'est l'édit
de Villers-Cotterêts dont aujourd'hui on
retient simplement l'article qui
explique qu'on va écrire tout en
français enfin qui dit plein d'autres
choses et pas toutes glorieuses pas
toutes glorieuses mais enfin qui dit ça
le Collège de France c'est-à-dire l'idée
que le savoir
et la connaissance ne doivent pas être
réservés
à la Sorbonne et à l'université
ta croyable et la ville du hard mais je
dis je peux pas l'oublier c'est une idée
d'une incroyable modernité me
semble-t-il donc la fondation et puis
Henri IV c'est la réconciliation et
comme vous allez tous vous jeter sur le
livre qui est d'ailleurs épuisé
François en tout cas moi j'ai pas réussi
à l'acheter j'ai dû l'emprunter dans une
bibliothèque heureusement bien
achalandée au Havre
vous y trouverez un chapitre qui
s'appelle l'art de gouverner et vous
voyez que Henri IV confronté à des
difficultés considérables ce qui laisse
d'ailleurs permet de mettre un peu de
distance entre ce qu'on vit parce qu'il
y a d'autres moments dans l'histoire de
France où il y a eu des difficultés
considérables j'ai quand même réappris
pour tout dire en fait un peu appris que
l'excellent Henri IV avait dans un
moment de grande difficulté conçu l'idée
d'une forme de de grand débat
mais c'est vrai deux grands débats dont
il a d'ailleurs pas suivi tous les
enseignements sur le conseil de Sully
j'ai découvert les agacements profonds
d'Henri IV face au Parlement qui était à
l'époque plutôt la justice que que le
système parlementaire profond je l'ai
découvert incroyablement attaché au bon
état des finances publiques lui-même
disant et franchement ça devrait nous
faire réfléchir qui ne pouvait pas y
avoir de réconciliation en français sans
finance publique tenue
c'est
enfin ça fait réfléchir parce que c'est
écrit il y a longtemps mais ça reste à
mon avis extrêmement vrai et puis la
dernière chose puisque j'étais à
Fontainebleau avec Jean-Paul puis à la
naissance de renaissance et que
maintenant je suis avec François
l'édit de Nantes c'est-à-dire au fond un
texte qui d'une certaine façon pourrait
avoir valeur constitutionnelle l'idée
que on organise par le droit une forme
de liberté et notamment de liberté
religieuse ce qui est totalement nouveau
dans le monde de l'époque qui me paraît
pas complètement là non plus dépassée
voir déplacer et qui sera abrogé en 1685
à Fontainebleau par Louis XIV bref
dans le moment où nous vivons dans le
moment où Renaissance secret dans le
moment où nous sommes confrontés à de
telles difficultés je pense que notre
objectif celui qui nous réunit celui sur
lequel nous pouvons partager celui sur
lequel nous pouvons construire c'est au
fond l'objectif même de ces deux
souverains de la Renaissance fondé la
nouvelle puissance française
et réconcilier les Français la puissance
c'est pas quelque chose d'hégémonique
c'est quelque chose qui sert à faire
prévaloir ses intérêts et être à la
hauteur face aux enjeux du monde
fonder et refonder les éléments de la
puissance française et réconcilier les
Françaises et les Français avec
eux-mêmes d'une certaine façon et d'une
certaine façon peut-être aussi avec la
France c'est ce que je nous souhaite
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]